Okay.
We've been covering the state level proposals
to make abortions almost or completely illegal.
Yesterday we talked about Alabama, no abortions,
other than exceptions for the health of the
mother on the program.
Tomorrow I'm going to talk about Missouri.
Uh, and I've already explained the sort of
underlying idea here, which is that you've
got a right wing Supreme Court now thanks
to Donald Trump more right wing than any court
we've had in a long time.
So the strategy is get some crazy bill passed
at the state level.
It will be immediately appealed and challenged
and more than likely because it's so whacked
out and in many ways would conflict with Roe
v Wade.
It is likely to be struck down by a lower
court, appeal it all the way up to the Supreme
Court and then hopefully get a decision from
this very conservative supreme court that
will allow a national push back, uh, on abortion
regulations everywhere.
Um, there's a really good piece in vox that
explains that this is not just like a pipe
dream for the religious right, that this is
Roe v Wade in spirit and in name is in danger
because of this what I, what I called yesterday,
a very clever strategy by the religious right.
But what I want to talk about today is that
even if Roe v Wade stands legally speaking,
if it stays enacted in force, the spirit of
Robie Roe v Wade is in danger either way because
you can undo the effect of Roe versus Wade
without actually undoing roe versus wade in
and of itself.
And that is uh, sort of the premise of these
really extreme anti abortion bills that have
passed in 2019 four, five six depending on
how you're counting.
And at some point something is very likely
to get to the supreme court.
Okay.
That won't by definition get Roe v Wade overturned.
And there are more and more analysts that
are pointing out astutely that overturning
Roe v Wade may not even actually be the goal
of these hands.
High choice activists and it might not even
be the best thing for the anti choice movement.
The idea being if Roe v Wade stays as the
law, that emboldens and empowers the activism
of the Anti Choice Movement to say Roe v Wade
is still there, but we're working at the state
level to stop all abortion.
They can keep raising money around the issue
and you can do a lot of damage to abortion
rights without actually overturning Roe v
Wade itself.
Roe v Wade in 73, um, at the federal level
said abortion is legal up to a 22 to 24 weeks
in most cases.
And so the problem that a lot of states run
up against when they try to pass more restrictive
laws than that is that they conflict with
federal supremacy and Roe v Wade.
So that's why lower courts will typically
strike them down and the supreme court is
rarely going to hear them because it's pretty
clear that they conflict with Roe v Wade.
The idea here is you've got a particularly
conservative Supreme Court, if you can word
one of these bills in a way that may be some
element of it or along some very narrow legal
interpretation.
The law would be okay at the state level or
a part of the law would be okay at the state
level, you could get a ruling from this very
conservative supreme court that will without
overturning Roe v Wade in and of itself create
a framework or a sort of guide to how at the
state level you can pass something that would
be more restrictive than Roe v Wade.
The um, other practical matter, uh, that would
point to this being a better strategy than
just trying to get Roe v Wade overturned,
is that even the antiabortion Supreme Court
justices may not want to attach their names
to overturning Roe v Wade.
So whether Roe v Wade stays or goes in name,
the idea here is that the principles of roe
versus Wade can be dismantled by these endless
little cuts that could come as soon as one
of these state abortion bans gets to the supreme
court and gets a favorable ruling even in
some sense.
And then they can make a states be allowed
to have much more leeway in deciding what
to do about abortion.
And maybe the most important thing to remind
you about is that with lots of, uh, similarly
to lots of other political issues that are
great for angering people and for raising
money and for making noise.
Um, uh, uh, but not necessarily representative
of the national opinion.
Most of the American people are not on the
antiabortion side.
And we have sort of two important data points
on this.
Number one, for the first time ever, a few
years ago, support for abortion in what's
called most cases.
So obviously there are particular cases where
you do get a majority of the country say,
am I am against abortions in that particular
situation.
Um, in most cases, more than half the country
supports abortion.
And that is a, a number that was only first
achieved a couple of years ago, so was support
for abortion has been rising.
But even if you look at the individual state
level, there is not a single state where a
total abortion ban has even 25% support.
We're putting on the screen a data analysis
by data for progress from cooperative congressional
election studies data.
So understand that states are passing almost
total abortion bans, even though the people
in not a single state support that at even
a rate of 25%.
The problem is that abortion is a really strong
single issue.
Topic.
Guns, we've talked about guns.
People are very, uh, uh, a partisan and extreme.
And by by extreme, I don't mean extreme on
the political spectrum, but very ingrained
views about guns.
But it doesn't seem like guns are nearly as
much of a voting issue as other issues.
Abortion is a really big voting issue.
Donald Trump has lived a life completely antithetical
to evangelical Christianity.
Stated principles stated being a key word,
but in the end, evangelicals voted for Trump.
Why?
Because Trump now claims to be against abortion
and uh, Hillary Clinton is pro choice and
that actually is a big voting motivator for
people in lots of parts of the country.
So Roe v Wade is in serious danger, even if
the law in and of itself remains in force.
I told you exactly the way that it would happen
two years ago.
It is happening and if there's any wakeup
call here, it's, we cannot let Donald Trump
get a third supreme court pick.
We know how to prevent that from happening,
uh, at least potentially depending on what
happens in the next year and a half.
We've got to vote him out in November of 2020.
Make sure you're following the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Dot pacman.
I will be,
uh, photo blogging, my upcoming trip, which
I think many of you will find very interesting.
We'll take a quick break and be back after